can we get you to sing anything off the
chant record
what what give me a song up the chat
record okay okay thank you
my heart in my heart and my heart
[Music]
is
[Music]
soundtrack was so influential
so huge
how exciting is that for you and is it
kind of crazy to you how much these
songs have stuck with people
yeah i mean this movie for it to be 20
years ago which is
insane to me i was 17. um
it is quite nuts and people really do
feel so nostalgic about the music
and about the film in general but um the
music really has seemed to to stick with
people like for
for all this time and they passed it
down to their
to their daughters so you're 17 and
you're standing and dancing on the bar
in the movie singing these songs what is
that moment like for you
uh i mean that moment is um that moment
was
awkward probably uh you know i mean i
was a kid i was a teenager um
still going into myself so it was fun
and it was awkward and i was
you know like trying to trying to be
this like
sexy singer performing on a bar
and that was so opposite of me i mean i
was really acting at the time because i
i was still figuring all that out about
myself so
yeah now it's a different story now if
you put me on a bar it's a different
story
you're singing these kind of sexy songs
and you're 17 and you don't really know
that romance yet now you've been with
eddie you guys are together is there any
song
from the coyotes ugly soundtrack that
you you maybe think about eddie a little
bit during
um i mean i would say right kind of
wrong it's probably like
you know he would be the right kind of
wrong um
definitely uh there's uh there's
something about him i really
actually do think of him when i think
that song um
yeah i mean if i think about it i'm like
yeah that that would be where i draw my
inspiration from for that
well i like that because you guys are
about to celebrate another or a big
anniversary as well right you guys are
coming up on 10 years
yeah isn't that insane it's yeah april
will be 10 years
um yeah it's just yeah i never
who who knew i mean i don't say i never
thought we would make it here i
definitely do
um i it's just i you think of 10 years
and you think of that being such a big
milestone for a couple
and um you know eddie's parents are
about to celebrate their 50th
which is so fantastic and uh you know to
be with him for 10 years has been
it's been a blessing it really has i
mean there's been
you know we've been we've been through a
lot of ups and downs as any couple um
but have always been super close and
connected and have each other's backs
he's a good dude he really is yeah i
mean you guys have you know you deal
with the kids stuff and the
homeschooling thing and covert
are you having zoom classes how's all
that going yeah zoom classes the kids
are now
13 and 17. so they're pretty solid i
just have to make sure that they're up
you know it's like hello are you up are
you awake like more than five minutes
before you're supposed to log on
they're great kids and they've grown
into really fantastic little men
and i'm i'm you know grateful that i'm
them in their life and yeah we are
we are we're doing the thing just like
everybody else you know no one's exempt
from this so
i um i hope that they get to go back to
school sooner than later i know they've
been looking forward to it
yeah well of course you're doing so much
you're releasing
another record right what can you tell
me about that i um well i have lots of
things going on at this moment yes uh i
have a
chant album that is coming out um this
is something that i have
been working on now for the last year
and
i've you know my my whole journey with
spirituality and just
meditation and and my own you know just
really coming back home to myself and my
wholeness has
been a journey of the last probably
eight years and
chanting has been one way where i've
been able to to really take my voice
back for myself you know i've given it
out so much to the worlds and
and i've never really used it for my own
healing and so chanting became a
a piece of my my daily um
self-exploration and so
i thought well i kind of write chants
all the time because i write courses
and courses are repetitive and yeah
they're basically chant so i said well
why don't i
kind of blend both and make a modern
chant record and so
that's how that came about and i
literally would sit down to my
meditations and
i would just start singing with my eyes
closed and allow things to just flow
through me and
when i found something i liked i would
record it and so it was really
channeled um you know for i think and
for this time i mean who knew this was
going to be
the most perfect time but i think
obviously there's something above that
does
and um and wanted to work through me in
this way so i
i hope that people i hope that people
can find their own voice within this
record and
to you know it's not something you you
can sit down with it and chant along or
i feel like it's something you can just
play in the background and it's super
soothing and
relaxing people need that can we get you
to sing
anything off the chant record what what
give me a song up the chat record okay
okay thank you
[Music]
is
[Music]
there you go i'm like i could end in the
middle but i'm like those chants are
kind of short i can just sing the whole
thing
and it is your gift oh my god oh thank
you
what about the podcast so the podcast is
just another extension of that i mean
my journey has been you know utilizing
ways to
and discovering ways really to use
utilize my voice
for for healing and for um the expansion
of myself and others and
you know the the chat record is a new
way to use that and and the
the podcast is another way i'm finding
that i i get to discover
another piece of me and it's called the
it's called the holy human w-h-o-l-o-y
um kind of a spin on both because i i
feel like as our wholeness we are
both human and holy and when one of
those pieces of us
when we cut one of those off in any way
we start to fragment ourselves and
i think that's a look i mean look around
this is the world we're living in is a
lot of fragmentation so
i'm hoping through this podcast with
sharing my own personal stories and
with connecting people with some
fantastic um
teachers and just interesting
interesting minds and hearts that
you know we're able to come back into to
hold us together because i i know that's
been my journey and i
i hope that i can be a leader um and
helping people come back together so
i mean you're you are such a again
somebody who's
like you said you i feel like you've
seen so much of the world you've been
famous since you were young
[Music]
you have so much perspective um and i i
think so many women in country music
look up to you
how would you describe the current state
of things somebody who's been in the
industry since you were a young teenager
how would you describe the state of
representation for women in country
music
now versus the days when you know shania
and faith and and those women
were really on top what do you think's
changed if anything
i don't think a lot has changed sadly um
i think that it's you know unfortunately
you know women have to fight incredibly
hard to have a place in country music
and and to have a voice in general i
mean it's just something it's not just
in country music we're living in a very
patriarchal society still and
that just seems to be the case um women
are still fighting for our
you know quote-unquote place in this
world and um
there's some fantastic artists that are
in country music now i know the one
thing that has changed
um you know when i was when i was really
in country music very early on there was
a
big line drawn as far as like you know
you can't cross over
you're you know you're gonna be disowned
that kind of thing um and so that was
you know when i did crossover that was a
that was something i had to contend with
and i think now the the line in the sand
is much
more blurred than it ever has been and
and women are
women are getting to utilize that and
and play around
a lot more than in the in the different
genres of music than
um than back in the past and so i'm i'm
glad that that is
available yeah um you know unfortunately
back in the day we we really had to
fight for that and
and i'm glad i did um i wouldn't change
anything i mean
look at what it's you know where it's
brought me uh but i
um you know and for me like music is
just
music is a playground and i think that's
the way it should be for any artist when
you start to try to put them into a box
it's really sad you stifle so much of
them so
i'm glad that the women are at least
have that and and i
you know i think that is there is a
there is a piece that is starting to
happen where where women are
being heard more and played more but you
kind of see
the chess piece move and you're like
hoping that it's going to expand and
then like
it gets moved backwards and um so i'm
i'm waiting for that door to really be
blown off and
i hope that happens later why why is it
a step forward and then a little bit
back
it's a man's world yeah because it's a
man's world
it's a good avoid game i mean yeah
exactly i'll sing it for you let me tell
you about it
um yeah no it's it's a good old boy game
and and you know
i had it kind of doubly going against me
as a kid because i was the kid and i was
a woman
you know i was a child um and i remember
like starting very young and having
people tell me like we don't
we don't want in their mind it was like
we don't want another tanya sucker we
don't want another young kid
and we don't want another woman is also
what was that you know
what was basically was underlying there
and um
yeah i fought against a lot of it and
i'm still standing and so
you know and that's and i know i'll know
i'll for
rey back into that and and you know i
have plans to
to play around in that area again so you
know
when you're young you're like god i hope
everybody likes me and i'm like
well if someone doesn't like me i'm
doing my job like that's a good thing
it's like totally change get him talking
because then you're you're making
people think a hundred percent um we i'm
speaking of
uh getting to people thinking transition
but i do have to ask you about
a little speculation i know you got a
lot in your schedule people are
wondering if you managed to fit in
the masked singer what do you say to
people who think you are on the show
i have been on that show now for every
season that it's been on
i have my whole twitter account has
always flooded with people like
you're i don't even know who they
thought i've been in the past but
constantly
on that show so i'll forever be on that
show even next year
well if you ever do any reality tv i've
heard these cries from fans before like
they
they'd want to see you and eddie on a
show you know i mean there's always talk
about
who who could be cast on housewives any
of the franchises
no i don't think so i think i'm good um
yeah no i i it just depends on what
reality television it is i mean i've you
know i've played around in that arena
and um i like
my reality a lot better i like to remain
present in my reality um yeah no i i
don't know we'll see
we'll see what happens as the as the
world turns but um
yeah i'm always open to playing but it
just has to be the right thing
um okay and then uh well
can you deny for me that you're not on
the math singer
i mean why you keep going down
yeah i'm not on the master okay
she's not would you ever do it
[Music]
maybe
you